okay this is a cool following 60. and
she's been with 60 guys in a gang bang
does it matter
[Music]
oh yeah you find out you're dating a
girl she's great okay
she's she's good in bed has all the
values you're looking for okay perfect
yep then you find out
um
she let five guys hit it in one night
in college
do you care
i don't think so everyone's got a
history
it's blue pale thinking
you know there's things in my history
that i wouldn't say i regret because
there's nothing regretting anything
you've done you just learn from it do
you feel like it's different from men
and women sleeping around
when how it feels or the opinion of it
no yeah like the opinion of it
well yeah guys sleeping around has
seemed like he's a lad top geezer yeah
whereas a woman she's seen as
her yeah
yeah it's kind of a double standard yeah
yeah
it's the biggest double standard there
is yeah like so that's why when i was
kind of getting at earlier like even if
you had stuff because
like when women sleep with men it's a
sign of pre-selection so like back in
the day
we had to pick a mate we would want a
guy that protected other women so like
that's why it's like a double standard
because there's biological reasoning
where men don't like it because
they needed to ensure paternity and a
girl that was sleeping around like you
don't know if that's the paternity of
your kid
so there's like biological reasons
behind double standards okay
yeah i'll get that yeah
yeah so yeah it's how it seemed today
really yeah
i i would tell my brother to avoid a
girl that sleeps around a lot to be
honest that's what i tell him
but then would you ever see yourself as
someone who sleeps around a lot i don't
no no i don't
what's your opinion on girls who do
um any of your teammates
don't go there
no i mean it's all it all depends right
like there's individual differences
but i think girls that sleep around a
lot have a harder time like being
faithful at times if i'm being honest
is there a reason a girl sleeps around a
lot
um
attention validation
and she just needs to find the right guy
sometimes yeah you're right sometimes
but i talk about general advice not
specifics you know like i can always
think of exceptions to the role
[Music]
okay
but
what else do i want to ask you is the
whole phase necessary you don't want to
talk about why you guys broke up
no that is deep that is deep that's
right
psychology you could do your master's
dissertation on that
but it wasn't cheating no no no no no
but it wasn't cheating huh
but
i mean if you're not sleeping together
for months like i feel like if a guy
isn't getting it from you like he's
either going to break up with you or go
somewhere else
it's not the reason no but because of
the other things going on
yeah
i lost the sexual attraction
oh really but then i didn't feel the
need to go out and get it elsewhere yeah
because i still wanted to stay loyal and
try work things
and get through it but
it just went on and on and couldn't get
through it
and
[Music]
very vague
i'm sorry i'm nosy that's fine
so
was it you lost the track did she like
gain weight or something no no
i'm not that shallow
wasn't like gaining weight it wasn't
was it like was it oh was it was it
jealous behavior
jenna's behavior yeah
nah should trust me this answer isn't
going to come out online
okay okay
have you ever dealt with jealousy like
are you a jealous guy
i'd say i can't be a jedis guy yeah i'm
kind of jealous have you ever have you
ever gone through a girl's phone no no i
won't go through her phone no
she's gone through mine yeah i think
every girl has at some point
but maybe there was reason to go through
mine
yeah
in the first couple of years like i did
still have tinder and stuff like that
are you a tinder yeah yeah
but that's like how do you say no one
cheated
if you would tender
you just never met with anyone else no
no
so i was like then why have it
i don't know how 17 is stupid oh yeah
yeah
yeah okay i got you
interesting
the whole phase necessary
what have you done to like get over your
past relationship did you
um
like what's helped you get through it
because i can't even imagine eight years
even even if you weren't emotionally
involved that's still a lot
um
i think i've just
obviously where it was my decision there
wasn't particularly too much heartbreak
on my side which i'm not cold-hearted
and i'm not just over it like that yeah
eight years is a long time
but
i think just trying to
get out there be myself again and be
happy
what advice would you have for someone
that's going through a breakup
[Music]
if you don't feel like you can be
yourself in that relationship
however hard it is
saying no to that person you don't want
to be together you've got to do it for
your own
like well-being
because
again it's horrible to say but i'm
happier now yeah
no disrespect to her but i'm happier now
no me too yeah me too like i understand
it's
hard to say like no you don't want to be
mean but
it's freedom and a bit of like weight
off your shoulders like i said earlier
shut your weight off your shoulders
exactly like i don't know
i was in a very like
like very like he was jealous kind of
controlling you know that type of thing
and like just like i felt like i was a
like a kid getting like
how do i put it like let at like like
your parents like getting out of my
parents house because
i
was so tired of like having to like
answer to someone all the time you know
what i mean like
yeah that's
how i felt that i just couldn't be
myself anymore
if we were still in the relationship i
wouldn't be here tonight yeah or come on
any of the other shows because i just
feel
i have to be there with her yeah
yeah because now i'm just like
a free man did you come to that party i
threw when i first got here nope oh no
it's funny because when did you get here
though because i joined volleyball late
november
well i got here october 15th okay or
20th like something like that and then
i threw that party for my birthday it
was like the fourth
no you weren't there
i didn't know anyone though so it was
kind of like oh my god there was so much
going on yeah it was also like when i
started uni
was i was still with her so very much
i'd be on campus
do my lectures do my volleyball go home
to her
whereas now i'm more just out there
myself
being around other people do you guys
have intertwined friend groups because i
didn't with my ex-boyfriend and that
made it a lot easier but i